historian Yuval Noah Harari and
entrepreneur Mustafa Suleiman are two of
the most important voices in the
increasingly contentious debate over AI
the economists got them together to
discuss how Humanity should deal with
the risks and opportunities of this
technological Revolution
this is a moment when we collectively in
the west have to establish our values
and stand behind them
[Music]
you well know how
the historian thank you for joining us
wonderful that you can join us too
you're a friend of The Economist a
fellow director in The Economist board
you were a co-founder of deepmind you're
now a co-founder and CEO of inflection
AI so let's take five years
2028 what does the world look like in
the next five years the Frontier Model
companies those of us at the very
Cutting Edge who are training the very
largest AI models are going to train
models that are over a thousand times
larger than what you currently see today
in gpt4 instead of just generate new
text in a one shot the model will be
able to generate a sequence of actions
over time and I think that that's really
the character of AI that we'll see in
the next five years artificial capable
AIS AIS that can't just say things they
can also do things but what does that
actually mean in practice just just you
know use your imagination tell me what
my life will be like in 2028 it will be
able to make phone calls to other humans
to negotiate it'll be able to call other
AIS in order to establish the right
sequence in a supply chain for example
and of course it will learn to use apis
application programming interfaces so
other websites or other knowledge bases
or other information stores and so you
know the world is your oyster you could
imagine mention that being applied to
many many different parts of our economy
so you about a man who doesn't use a
smartphone very much you listen to this
does this fill you with horror or and do
you agree with it I will take it very
seriously I don't know I'm not coming
from within the industry so I cannot
comment on how How likely it is to
happen but when I hear this as a
historian for me what we just heard this
is the end of human history not the end
of History the end of human dominated
history history will continue with
somebody else in control because what we
just heard is basically Mustafa telling
us that in five years they'll be a
technology that can make decisions
independently and that can create new
ideas independently this is the first
time in history we confronted something
like this I think it's important to say
these are not autonomous tools by by
default these these capabilities don't
just naturally emerge from the models we
attempt to engineer capabilities and the
challenge for us is to be very
deliberate and precise and careful about
those capabilities that we want to
emerge from the model that we want to
build into the model and the constraints
that we build around it it's super
important not to anthropomorphically
project ideas and you know potential
intentions or potential agency or
potential autonomy into these models the
governance challenge for us over the
next couple of decades to ensure that we
contain this wave is to ensure that we
always get to impose our constraints on
the development of this trajectory the
trajectory of this development this kind
of containment as as Mustafa calls it be
done when you have the sort of tensions
you've got between the world's big
players I mean this is the biggest
problem that if it was a question of you
know humankind versus a common threat of
these new intelligent alien agents here
on Earth then yes I think that there are
ways we can contain them but if the
humans are divided among themselves and
are in an arms race then it's because it
becomes almost impossible to contain
this alien intelligence and and there is
I I'm tending to think of it more in in
terms of of really an alien invasion
that like somebody coming and telling us
that you know there is a fleet an alien
Fleet of spaceships coming from planet
Zircon or whatever with super with
highly intelligent beings they'll be
here in five years and take over the
planet maybe they'll be nice maybe
they'll solve cancer and climate change
but we are not sure
this is what we are facing except that
the aliens are not coming in spaceships
from planet Zircon that are coming from
the laboratory
characterization of the nature of the
technology and alien Alias by default
agency these are going to be tools that
we can apply
yes but let's say they have they
potentially have agency we can try to
prevent them from having agency but we
know that they are going to be highly
intelligent and at least potentially
have agency and this is a very very
frightening mix
something we never confronted before
again atom bombs didn't have a potential
for agency printing presses did not have
a potential for agency this thing again
unless we contain it and the problem of
continuity is very difficult because
potentially they'll be more intelligent
than us how do you prevent something
more intelligent than you from become
from developing the agency it has I'm
not saying it's impossible I'm just
saying it it's very very difficult
I appreciate that there are actors in
the private sector like Mustafa who are
thinking very seriously about regulation
and containment but we must have an
external entity
in in the game and for that we need to
develop new institutions that will have
the human resources that will have the
the economic and technological resources
and also will have the public trust
because without public trust it won't
work are we capable of creating such new
institutions I don't know I do think
eval raise is an important point you
their creators can't quite predict what
powers they will have
they may not be fully autonomous but
they will be moving some ways towards
there and so how do you guard against
that when you pressure test them you try
to make them think you can't pressure
test for everything in advance so there
is a I think a very real point that
Yuval is making about as the
capabilities increase
so the risks increase of relying on you
and other Creator companies to to I mean
it's a very fair question and that's why
I've long been calling for the
precautionary principle we should both
take some capabilities off the table and
classify those as high risk I mean
frankly the EU AI act which has been in
draft for three and a half years is very
sensible as a risk-based framework that
applies to each application domain
whether it's health care or self-driving
or facial recognition and it basically
takes certain capabilities off the table
when that threshold is exceeded I listed
a few earlier autonomy for examples
clearly a capability that it has the
potential to be high risk recursive
self-improvement the same story so this
is the moment when we have to adopt a
precautionary principle not through any
fear-mongering but just as a logical
sensible way to proceed is it sensible
for a country to rule out certain
capabilities if the other side is not
going to rule them out this is a moment
when we collectively in the west have to
establish our values and stand behind
them what we cannot have is a race to
the bottom that says just because
they're doing it we should take the same
risk if we adopt that approach and cut
Corners left right and Center we'll
ultimately pay the price we didn't agree
about much but I completely agree on
that that we need in many fields a
coalition of the willing and if some
actors in the world don't want to join
it's it's in our interest
to again something like Banning Bots
impersonating people so some countries
will not agree but that doesn't matter
to protect our societies it's still a
very good idea to have these kinds of
regulations
thanks for watching
to watch the full debate covering
subjects from the impact of AI
unemployment and geopolitics to the
survival of liberal democracy click the
link and subscribe
[Music]